- Welcome back from
the break, everybody.
We're going to proceed
with our final panel
now, a panel on
citizenship on the move.
And may I ask the panel
members to come up to the stage
and take their seats while I
have the honor of introducing
Professor Jacqueline Bhabha.
Professor Jacqueline
Bhabha is the director
of research at the Harvard FXB
Center for Health and Human
Rights, a professor of
the practice of health
and human rights at the
Harvard T.H. Chan School
of Public Health, and
also an adjunct lecturer
in public policy at the
Harvard Kennedy School.
Before coming to Harvard,
she directed the Human Rights
Program at the
University of Chicago
and was a practicing human
rights lawyer in London
at the European Court of
Human Rights in Strasbourg.
She's published extensively on
issues of transnational child
migration, refugee
protection, children's rights,
and citizenship.
Most recently, she is the author
of Can We Solve the Migration
Crisis? and Child Migration and
Human Rights in a Global Age.
She will be
moderating this panel.
Professor Bhabha,
thank you very much.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you all so much
for still being here.
You must pity us.
A rather daunting task, first
of all, to be the last panel.
And secondly, to be the last
panel after the keynote speech
we've just had.
So please bear with us.
We'll do our very best to
be stimulating and engaging.
So I'm going to make a couple
of introductory remarks
before I briefly introduce
our three panelists.
This conference, I
think-- our panel
is entitled "Citizenship
on the Move."
And I think this
conference has already
demonstrated very clearly how
citizenship is on the move,
if you like.
Moving between assimilating
native peoples on the one
hand, peoples who want to
preserve their nationhood,
and excluding
Puerto Ricans-- who
are citizens-- on the other.
Choking out citizens'
labor rights,
imposing reductive physical
tests of belonging on tribes.
So all these different types
of movement that citizenship
is engaged in.
So we've come a long way
from the early discussions
of citizenship
that T.H. Marshall,
the famous British
sociologist who
wrote first, very
comprehensively,
about citizenship from
the issues he addressed.
He said that citizenship really
consisted of three elements--
civil, political, and
social citizenship.
And he said civil and political
citizenship were really one
in the 18th and 19th centuries.
And they were a
product, if you like,
of the Euro-American
political transformations
in state governance.
And that social
citizenship was a product
of the post-war period
of kind of welfarism.
And so he saw these three
elements of citizenship
as kind of capturing
some of what
we think of now as
fundamental human rights.
So political citizenship
is about, for example,
the right to vote--
a right that Puerto Ricans,
as we've just heard,
don't really have.
Civil citizenship
is about issues
such as freedom of speech.
And then social citizenship
is about social rights
such as the right to education
or to social insurance.
Now, two of Marshall's
constitutive elements
of citizenship are
actually no longer confined
to citizens at all.
They aren't constitutive
of citizenship.
So if you think of the
right to free speech,
it actually is a human right
that belongs to everyone.
Whether you're a
citizen or noncitizen,
whether you're documented
or undocumented,
it's a fundamental human right.
And similarly, in many
countries, including this one,
the right to education
and other social rights
also belong to non-citizens.
Some, like the
right to education--
to primary education--
belong to any child who is in
the jurisdiction, irrespective
of their legal status.
Some, like social
insurance, belong to people
who have legal residence.
So a green card or some
form of permanent residence.
So citizenship, what we
think of as the core element
of citizenship, has also
moved in that sense--
that non-citizens,
residents, for example,
have many of the core
rights of citizenship.
And so I think this is a
very positive transformation.
I think the fact that
these constitutive elements
of citizenship have become
more broadly accessible
is a very positive move.
And it's now really
only political rights--
the right to vote--
that are jealously
guarded by citizens.
And even here, there
are some exceptions.
Now, as others
have said actually
in the course of this
wonderful conference,
this transformation
in citizenship--
in the landscape
of citizenship--
didn't happen as Marshall
suggested, somehow cumulatively
and progressively as a
kind of a force of nature.
It's a product of
contestation, of course.
Contestation on the streets,
contestation in parliament,
contestation in the courts.
Contestation about what
it means to be human
and about what the import
of these key human rights
principles--
such as non-discrimination--
should be, in terms of access
to these measures.
And so it's a happy thing
that citizenship has generally
been on the move.
But today, we see the
concept of citizenship,
I think, being on the move in a
much less inspiring direction.
Consider-- and I'm
going to just give you
a couple of
international examples.
Today, much of our discussion
has been focused on the US.
But consider the mobilization
of citizenship in India,
to privilege Hindu
beliefs and customs,
and this dreadful development
now around cow slaughter
that you may have
been following.
Consider the distortion of
the notion of citizenship
in Hungary to elevate
Christian beliefs and mores
over any other form
of European belonging,
even casting mosques as
somehow non-European.
And of course, closer
to home, consider
the current US administration's
willful obliteration
of the complex and multifaceted
history of the construction
of American citizenship
in his comments
about who are the
Americans that are supposed
to be becoming great again.
So citizenship discussions
have become, now,
a site for militant
exclusionary processes, which
they hadn't been, I
think, for some decades.
So we have a marvelous array of
panelists in this final session
to address these
unrelated issues.
And I'm going to
just give very brief
thumbnail biographical
sketches, because we all
have the booklet.
So our first speaker is Theresa
McCarthy, Onondaga Beaver Clan
of Six Nations of the Grand
River territory in Ontario
and an associate professor
of Native American studies
at the University of Buffalo.
She, I think, is going to
be a perfect person for us
to hear from in relation
to North American
citizenship and its moving
landscape and histories
and legacies.
Our second speaker
is Alexandra Stern,
who is a historian and an expert
on genetics in the Americas--
interesting and
unusual combination.
She is a professor
of American culture
and women's studies at
the University of Michigan
and an expert on the history
of eugenic sterilization.
She's actually
engaged in efforts
to address compulsory
sterilization, a very
live issue in many parts of
the world, not only in the US.
And I think, given
the discussion we've
been having about blood
proportions and blood count,
it's very interesting,
I think, to pick up
some of those conversations
about body and control of body
perhaps with this light.
And finally, last but of course
not least, Lyndsey Stonebridge,
who takes us across the
Atlantic to the EU and beyond.
She is a professor
of the humanities
and human rights at
University of Birmingham
and has worked on the
history of and responses
to violence, right
from Nuremberg
through to contemporary
refugee-related crises.
So she has a very
wide and very original
way of thinking about some of
the most egregious violations
in human history.
So please join me in welcoming
these three great panelists.
[APPLAUSE]
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Theresa
McCarthy [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So I just said, hello.
My indigenous name is [? Aida ?]
[? Ahta ?] and it means she
dries the clay.
I'm Theresa McCarthy.
I'm Onondaga Nation Beaver Clan.
And I'm grateful to be here with
you all today to share ideas
and to learn from
each other here
on the territory of the
Wampanoag and Massachusett
people.
Now, my comments today emphasize
how indigenous citizenship
further unsettles notions of
citizenship in settler nation
states.
I am interested in
talking about expressions
of indigenous citizenship that
transcend the nation state
borders imposed on
our homelands and that
exceed the current boundaries
over reservation territories.
My research foregrounds
Haudenosaunee women's
assertions of
citizenship through
the political
theorizing and action.
This is seen through the
work that our people,
and particularly
our women, engage in
to defy the extinguishment
of our territorial rights,
our political subjugation, the
eradication of our cultures
and languages, and our
compulsory enfranchisement
into the nation states
of the US and Canada.
Given my training as
an anthropologist,
another related
interest of mine is
on how historic academic work,
particularly 20th-century
scholarship on my
people, has served
to reinforce the
extinguishment of our rights.
Legions of
non-indigenous experts
who made long careers
of studying us
referred to us as the Iroquois.
And we remain the most
anthropologized indigenous
people in North America.
But we call ourselves
Haudenosaunee,
which means "they
build the house,"
in reference to our nations
coming together as one.
The Haudenosaunee are comprised
of six nations, the Mohawk,
Oneida, Onondaga, Cayuga,
Seneca, and Tuscarora.
We came together to become
a confederacy of nations,
the Haudenosaunee
Confederacy, in accordance
with the central teaching
of our cultural history,
the Gayanashagowa, or
the Great Law of Peace.
And it's from the
Gayanashagowa that we
derive our structure
of political leadership
and governance.
Our Confederacy remains
in operation today
as the oldest continuing
living participatory
democracy in the world.
The fact that, as
Haudenosaunee, we
remain a separate and distinct
political entity from Canada
and the United States, that
we have never surrendered
or relinquished our sovereignty,
that our historical presence,
and that our Confederacy
governance structure long
predates other nation state
formations on our territories,
are just some of the ways that
we unsettle normative thinking
about citizenship.
Our people remain adamant
that being enfolded
into US and Canadian citizenship
jeopardizes our sovereignty
and undermines our treaties.
It advances colonialism and,
in turn, our disappearance.
Since border crossing is
a theme of this panel,
I want to push our thinking
about borders further today.
The Haudenosaunee are a
border-crossed people.
The Canada and US
international border
bisects our homelands, meaning
that our peoples rights
to declare who we
are and move freely
on our ancestral territories
are constantly challenged
by foreign governments.
These borders are not supposed
to exist for the Haudenosaunee.
They have no basis
in our cosmologies,
and they were never meant to
inhibit our freedom of movement
according to historic treaties.
But these provisions
are rarely upheld,
because they aren't
widely understood.
It's rare to find border
guards, customs agents, or even
immigration lawyers, who
know anything about them.
This ignorance
results in a myriad
of consequences for our people.
Delay, detainment,
denial of entry,
deportation, and historically,
even incarceration.
Our additional laws
and legislation
in Canada and the US further
strangulate these rights,
so that something that is
not supposed to exist--
this settler-colonial construct,
this figment of the colonial
imagination--
has very real political
and legal consequences
for our people.
Now, to briefly
illustrate, here is a map.
It's not perfectly
to scale, but it
outlines our
traditional territories
and locates our
contemporary settlements,
and shows the Canada-US border
cutting through our homelands.
In the Northeastern region, it
runs through Akwesasne Mohawk
territory, meaning that border
crossing is a daily experience
for them, as is grappling with
the distinct jurisdictions
of Ontario and New
York State, which
also bisects their territory.
And although this
complexity is concentrated
in just one place
in a particular way,
this reality is something
which all Haudenosaunee
as border-crossed
people must contend.
When I look at this map, I see
a legal and political minefield
of an enormous magnitude
that has literally
ripped our people apart.
Thinking just in terms of
the implications arising
from Canadian and US
Indian policy alone--
this endless
enormous bureaucracy
of legal imposition.
The Bureau of Indian
Affairs, the Department
of Indian Affairs, the Indian
Act, colonial band councils,
IRA governments, all of it.
Right?
And the depth of
this impact that it's
had for over a century
on our people--
close to two centuries--
constantly undermining
who we are, our connections to
each other, and our homelands.
It's just astounding.
And this is why, in my work,
I expend a lot of energy
taking non-indigenous
scholars to task
who studied our
people for the ways
that they discredit our
contemporary political
assertions, by
scrutinizing the complexity
of our colonial entanglements
as evidence of our disarray
and decline.
In particular, I look at
the pathologizing narrative
of Iroquois
factionalism-- this idea
that we're constantly in
conflict and infighting that's
meant to maintain colonial
hierarchies while remaining
unaccountable to land theft
or to institutional structures
intended to eliminate
indigenous people.
For the Haudenosaunee,
settler nation state borders,
like the northern Canada-US
international borders,
are ongoing sites of
colonialism, imperialism,
and empire, where our histories,
our distinct political
identities, and our
relationships to our homelands
are erased and invisible.
But these are not
the only borders
through indigenous
territories where this occurs.
As folks who do critical
border studies tell us,
borders are multiple
and movable sites
existing beyond the established
physical structures and spaces
where the edges of
nation states meet.
With this in mind, it's
important to think about nation
state border-making
practices involving
development and
corporate resource
extraction on indigenous lands.
So that this is a border.
This is a slide on
[INAUDIBLE] territory
militarized law enforcement
protecting hydro fracking
operations by a
Texas-based oil company
in New Brunswick in 2013.
And this is a border.
This is Cannonball,
North Dakota,
against the Dakota
Access Pipeline.
This is a border site.
This is the same place,
Cannonball, North Dakota
against Dakota Access Pipeline.
Again, militarized police
protecting Energy Transfer
Partners.
And this is a border.
This is the RCMP invasion of
unceded Wet'suwet'en territory
in northern BC.
Again, coming in to
protect the interests
of putting oil pipeline through
those unceded territories.
And this is a border.
This is a little
bit harder to see.
But this is militarized
law enforcement
at the height of tensions
involving the 2006 reclamation
of Six Nations lands
at [INAUDIBLE],,
meaning "the protected
place," which
is involving my community.
And this is another.
You can see just in the
background that militarized
law enforcement there.
So these depictions of
recent settler state
border-making practices,
which are advancing
the rights of corporate
and settler state
citizens on our land, expand
but replicate historic patterns
of colonial violence.
They elicit massive responses
from indigenous peoples,
united to stand against this
violence and exploitation.
We can also look
at the indigenous
front lines that form to
confront and challenge
these exploitations
as borderlands, where
we see our people
asserting their citizenship
and practicing their
sovereignty in the service
not only of ourselves but of
everyone's continued existence.
Because what's happening
at these border sites with
hydro-fracking, oil
pipelines, mega development,
cannot be contained.
Ecological destruction, climate
change, water contamination,
pollution, they render
all borders meaningless.
So assertions of indigenous
sovereignty and citizenship
at these sites are invaluable.
I want to turn to
briefly provide
a frame of reference
for what citizenship
means to Haudenosaunee people.
One of the ways I like to
look at Haudenosaunee women's
political theorizing is by
shining a light on our people's
artistic brilliance.
It is important to highlight
and center this knowledge
and to know that there
is an invaluable archive
of information on Haudenosaunee
women's political theory
out there.
Not all of it is written down.
A lot of it is,
but not all of it.
But there are other
places to look.
So this is Mohawk artist Shelley
Niro's multimedia piece Time
Travels Through Us.
And just a little bit from
the image description,
in case it's a little
bit hard to see, and just
to give you a little bit
of background-- in it,
Niro presents her mother
and two daughters,
the trio representing
the social, cultural,
and personal values that have
been transmitted from one
generation to the next.
The turtle, which is Niro's
clan animal, and it's a pendant
on her necklace and the central
animal of the Haudenosaunee
creation story, also
figures in the piece.
Now, this piece provides
a beautiful visual
that encourages
generative thinking
about the centrality of
women and our understandings
of Haudenosaunee citizenship
and political structure.
As a matrilineal people,
we inherit our clans
and our nations through
our mothers line.
And women play an
invaluable leadership role
in our government structure--
selecting, directing, and when
necessary, deposing our Chiefs.
Caretaking of the land is
also invested with the women.
Our clans our extended
kinship structures
that are the building
blocks of our governance.
They orient our structure of
relationality, responsibility,
and accountability to each
other and to creation.
And this is an active
process reinforced
in the verbal structures
of our language, which
denote the action of being
in relation as something that
is always ongoing.
And lastly, I just love how
Niro invokes time in this piece.
The importance of
this relationality,
of honoring life, and of how
these responsibilities move
through us across
time through past,
present, and onward
to future generations.
OK.
This is another important
model for understanding
the Haudenosaunee Confederacy.
This is Mohawk artist
Elizabeth Doxtater's
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
which means "it encircles
everything."
This is Doxtater's
visual narrative
of the Great Law of Peace
from which our Confederacy
governance arises.
Most of our people who
think about the great law
and of our political system
and how it came to be sort of
think about it as
an oral narrative,
because it's mainly communicated
as an oral narrative.
And we don't often encounter
a woman's rendering
of this teaching.
Doxtater's piece gives us
a three-dimensional sense
of the magnitude
of representation
that our people have within
our Confederacy system.
And just a lot of people can't
visualize what it looks like.
Her decision to bring
women to the forefront
reminds us that the Confederacy
is not just a chief's council
but, rather, a collective
union of clan families
that represents all the people.
Doxtater also anchors the
Gayanashagowa in the land
through her use of the
corn husk in this piece.
Because it's all made
out of corn husk dolls.
And she explains that
working with the corn husk
is quote, "like reaching
back to the time
of her ancient ancestors.
Corn is still grown
and harvested,
the husks still
braided, it is still
ceremonially celebrated
the same as it has
been for thousands of years."
End quote.
So these two amazing
artistic works
can also help illuminate how
the use of these status terms
and concepts like citizen,
nation, and sovereignty, when
informed by additional
understandings,
bear little resemblance to
Western legal interpretations.
And as with lots of words
in the English language,
indigenous people make them
their own, extending them
so that they are
infected with meaning
derived from our languages
and intellectual traditions.
So one example, for
example, the translation
of the Mohawk word
for nationality
literally means
"bodies in the land."
OK.
So the Haudenosaunee
have a long history
of asserting and
practicing sovereignty
in ways that also help others.
And an example that began in
the early 20th century involving
a Confederacy chief, Deskaheh,
whose name was Levi General--
his travels from Six
Nations at Grand River
to the League of Nations
in Geneva, Switzerland
to petition for recognition
of Haudenosaunee sovereignty
just as Canada's termination
efforts were really
bearing down on our community.
His petition did not achieve
its desired outcome at the time,
and he was punished
for his actions.
When he returned from overseas,
the federal government
would not allow him
to return to Canada,
forcing him to remain
in the United States,
where he died
shortly thereafter.
But his efforts
became a catalyst
for future generations
of Haudenosaunee people
who have worked
tirelessly to enable
what he was trying to accomplish
and to honor his sacrifices.
We can see this today through
Haudenosaunee contributions
to creating, expanding,
and sustaining
a global regime of human rights
that centers indigenous people.
Closer to home, Deskaheh's
work inspired the formation
of the Indian Defense League of
America, which since 1926 has
worked to uphold Haudenosaunee
people's rights to freely cross
the borders on our homelands.
Back to indigenous women.
OK.
Indigenous women's leadership
is exerted in formidable ways
at the front lines of our
contemporary struggles
to protect the lands and waters.
At these most recent
instantiations
of nation state borders
on our territories,
we always see women
at the forefront
as those who are most
compelled to push back
against the colonial
power that relentlessly
tries to shape their lives.
The architects of our 2006
land reclamation movement
at Six Nations--
Dawn Smith, who is Onondaga
Eel clan, and Jamie Jamieson,
who is Mohawk Turtle clan--
were two young
struggling single mothers
who had already endured
hardships and tragedies that
would break anyone when
they decided to take action.
Neither of them
would have ever said
that they were ever the perfect
embodiment of Haudenosaunee
values, but both of them
saw the consequences
of further encroachment on Six
Nations' land as unbearable.
And with, initially, only
a handful of others--
this is just the
group the first day--
resolved to put their
bodies on the line.
And as a result, this
was the first time
in 200 years of Haudenosaunee
history at Grand River
that our people actually managed
to regain rather than lose
our lands.
So what is often
mischaracterized
as resistance or activism is
really just the doing part
of Haudenosaunee citizenship--
declaring our citizenship as
sovereign indigenous nations
through our action
at these new border
sites emerging on our lands.
Understanding that the
purpose of these movements--
to defend land,
to protect water--
resides in promoting a
future-oriented consciousness
grounded in doing this
ongoing work to sustain life.
These are the ways that our
people transcend and exceed
the settler-state borders
imposed on our territories,
as we always have.
Just to leave with
some parting thoughts--
we encounter a lot of
pessimism, fatalism, cynicism
about our assertions
and movements.
And it's important to
address the pitfalls
of narrow definitions
of success or failure
in settler-colonial contexts.
If the successes of
indigenous efforts
are narrowly defined by
the outcome of dismantling
entire settler-colonial
structures,
then it is unlikely that
successes could ever
be countered.
It's better to think about
how these movements succeed
despite these structures.
It's better to think about how
settler-colonial structures are
continually undermined by
the way in which our people
maintain commitments
to who we are
and to our relational
responsibilities.
And it is better to think
about how these understandings
continue to thrive, to guide
the politics of the present,
and to inspire greater
numbers of people
to see themselves in this light.
These are the victories that
are important to hang on to,
because these are the
victories that are going
to continue to move us forward.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I think as a sort of antidote,
sort of way through some of it,
I just want to
start by going back
to Teresa's last
slide, which had
a sign on it that
read, "refugees
welcome on native land."
And I think it's a mark
of the thoughtfulness
of this conference that a
conference on citizenship
decided to end with refugees,
i.e. the category of people
that many people think of as
being outside of citizenship.
And it's a deep and
unusual thoughtfulness
and I congratulate
the organizers
for how you've curated it.
It's kind of thoughtfulness
that we don't
see very much of at the moment.
And I think what
I've learned today,
and why I want to put those
two things together a bit,
is if you really want
to understand something
about the value of citizenship,
and what it means today,
we need to listen
to people who live
in the shadows of citizenship.
Because they know more--
they are the experts
on citizenship.
And that also provokes
another question,
which is what kind
of solidarities
can there be between
the people who live
in the shadows of citizenship?
And that's something, as
I've been listening today,
has come up again and again.
And that question of
solidarity, it seems to me,
is vitally important
for exactly the reasons
that Alexandra has just
explained to us, that it's
getting very, very dire.
In terms of refugees and
the question of citizenship,
what we have in my part of the
world in Europe and the country
I currently live in, the
UK, is a renewed appetite
for racialized de-citizenship--
de-citizenizing people
which we haven't seen in
Europe since the 20th century.
And the other reason
I think I want
to stick with that question of
solidarity or come back to it
towards the end is
that, again, we've
heard a question about what
kind of global citizenship
might we imagine today.
And what kind of global activism
might we try and re-imagine
today?
So my starting
point for my remarks
today are a quotation from
the historian Michael Barnett.
And this is from his study
of the United Nations' High
Commission for
Refugees, which was
established after the
war in the last century.
And he says, "Only a world
of sovereign states that had
categories of people called
'citizens' and were intent
on regulating population flows
could produce a legal category
of 'refugees.'"
So only the idea of a nation
state that has citizens
produces a category of refugees.
We have to think
the two together.
The one is the
other of the other.
Two case studies-- I'm
drawing on two case studies.
One is a project I finished last
year called "placeless people,"
which was just a literary and
intellectual history of how
the category of refugees
and statelessness
emerged in the last century, in
the middle of the 20th century.
And a key figure in my
thinking there and for today
was Hannah Arendt.
And what you have
here on your left
is Arendt's document
in lieu of a passport.
We've had loads of
citizenship documents today.
I want to gather
them all together
and put them in one place.
This is a document that
doesn't give citizenship.
It is a document that
testifies to statelessness.
And that's Arendt.
And you can see, that took
quite a lot of explaining.
If you think of our
digital coding of passports
and identity today.
This is quite [INAUDIBLE].
The other project is recent.
It's a project called
"refugee hosts."
And it's a project on
South-South Humanitarianism.
And refugee-refugee solidarity
in the global south,
particularly in the context
of hosting of Syrian refugees
in Jordan, Lebanon, and Turkey.
And as you all know I'm
sure, the most refugees
in the world today are being
hosted in other global south
countries.
You know, the idea of everyone
coming up to the global north
from across is a very minor
part of the global story.
And the second
slide I have here,
I found in the women's
bathroom of St. Joseph's
University in Beirut's
politics department.
This is the women's bathroom.
Jackie said I have an
unusual way through things,
like collecting
bathroom graffiti.
And in the women's
bathroom, that sign up there
says-- it's a classic--
you know, leave
the bathroom in the state
you'd like to find it.
And one of the woman
scholars has written,
no, leave the state in the
toilet where you found it.
And another scholar has
come along and said,
no, leave the nation state in
the toilet where you found it.
I'll come back to that point.
And I think my
argument is going to be
that the placeless
condition that Arendt
and others diagnosed and
lived in the last century
was disavowed in the
years that followed.
And it was disavowed
by a kind of emergence
of a global humanitarianism
that has failed.
And it continues to fail.
But that failure is
producing new articulations
of global citizenship
and humanitarianism
elsewhere in the world.
OK.
So citizenship is the
universal mark of belonging.
We've seen that today.
But it is also, as
Arendt rant argued,
a mask that we put on
in order to be legally,
politically, culturally,
and socially visible.
Now, as many
[INAUDIBLE] generation
of European Jewish refugees
discovered in the last century,
to cross the border, to
be pushed across a border,
was to experience the
mask of citizenship fall
from your face.
Quote, "On the day I lost
my Austrian passport,"
wrote Stefan Zweig,
"I discovered
that when you lose
your native land,
you are losing more than
a patch of territory
within set borders."
Zweig's desolation was absolute.
The mask fell, the man stumbled,
reached out to retrieve it,
and found his hand
clutching into air.
Now, Arendt was impatient
was Zweig's objection.
She thought he was
naive to expect
that the world would be pleased
to see the man behind the mask.
Quote, "Everywhere
the word 'exile'
which once had an
undertone of sacred awe,"
she wrote, stateless
herself in 1944, "now
provokes the idea of
something simultaneously
suspicious and unfortunate."
So now provokes the
idea of something
suspicious and unfortunate.
Exile, in other words, had
ceased to become awesome
once identity became associated
with the modern nation
state and the movement
of peoples administered,
regulated, and controlled.
Hence Barnett's point
about citizens and refugees
being two sides
of the same coin.
Now, Arendt's analysis
of what de-citizenship
meant for her generation of
refugees is now well known.
The world found nothing
sacred, she said,
in the abstract
nakedness of being human.
18th-century ideals of
universal citizenship,
which we've already heard were
already problematic, finally
bit the dust when, engulfed
by nationalism and racism,
the European state began
to decide who was a citizen
and who was not, leaving
hundreds of thousands
to the sovereign and arbitrary
decisions of other nations.
Awesome exile had been
replaced by a more
piteous and suspicious
placeless condition.
But the placeless
condition did not only
belong to refugees
and the stateless.
Existentially,
politically, legally,
placelessness also affected
and affected the supposedly
securely domiciled.
In quote, "their
complete dependence
on the compassion of others."
You don't have anything
else to rely on.
Not a politic, not a civic
society, not a social,
not a culture.
You are completely dependent
on the compassion of others.
Arendt wrote again in
'44, "the placeless
create an uncanny impression
of something utterly inhuman."
This is quite interesting.
Note that what she's saying
is that the dependence
on compassion alone produces the
idea of uncanniness or threat.
So Arendt is putting a
question mark on the idea
that simply more compassion
towards refugees,
a call we often hear
today, is what's required.
Importantly, what she was
also doing is anticipating
the moral and
political mess we get
in when compassion
becomes all that we
offer the world's refugees.
Now placeless people appear
as uncanny and threatening
because they remind
the securely citizened
of their own vulnerability.
The catch of panic when
you put your passport
in the wrong pocket.
The stiffening of
your body when you're
moved into an unexpected
immigration queue.
These feelings find a
tangible correlative
in the figure of the
placeless person.
So that I think what we
call a refugee crisis
are much better
thought of as being
crisis in the most intimate
feelings and meanings
of citizenship.
The two go together.
The placeless remind everyone
that we're only wearing a mask.
And I think, going
back to Alex's paper,
this is why the mirror to
the pathos as the merely
human face of the refugee
is the armored mask
of ideological hate.
When he wanted an image of
the inhumanity of totalitarian
nationalism in
1984, George Orwell
chose to describe a
boat of refugees being
bombed in the Mediterranean.
This is '44 or '47.
Winston Smith
records in his diary
how the audience
was much amused.
Now, naked
ideological aggression
as Alex has just shown
us and as we all know,
is now back in vogue.
And this weaponizing
of suspicion,
however, is not only an
anomaly in the history
that Jacqui mentioned of a
benign liberal humanitarianism.
I think it's kind
of its evil twin.
Postwar, the global
vulnerability
signaled by refugees
and the placeless
was displaced onto
the vulnerability
of the placeless themselves.
The fantasy of
citizenship, to go back
to Michael Barnett's quote,
fortified and protected itself,
and with it the idea of
national sovereignty,
by projecting that
vulnerability onto those
who continue to be
forced on the move,
particularly, and mostly
in the global south.
Everyone may be vulnerable.
But henceforth, the
category of the refugee
will carry that vulnerability
with her as, so to speak,
extra baggage.
Now as the issue
of placelessness
moved through a developing
global human rights regime,
those uncanny feelings Arendt
noted became institutionalized.
As she among others, including
the very controversial refugee
advocate and American
journalist Dorothy Thompson--
as they all predicted,
the more the world
became globalized, the more
the major states cooperated
to keep their power and
wealth, the more people
will be thrown into an
existence where they only had
their humanity to bargain with.
It didn't, of course,
start out that way.
Human rights, in [INAUDIBLE]
memorable, beautifully
ambitious formulation,
should have, could have,
transformed what he called
objects of compassion
into subjects of
international rights.
That was [INAUDIBLE]
ambition, is to turn--
no more objects of compassion.
Everyone needs to be a subject
of international right.
[INAUDIBLE] was dismayed--
in fact, he was furious--
when the drafters
of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights
weakened asylum rights
in article 14.
Now the Refugee
Convention, which
followed in 1951, and
still operative today--
it's important to remember-- was
designed not to give refugees
rights but to keep citizens
of sovereign states
secure by establishing a
system of burden-sharing
across the world.
[? Elfin ?] Rhys,
a Welsh theologian
involved with the
Palestinian refugee aid
effort at the time
of the convention
described early drafts of
the convention being like--
and I love this quote--
he said it's like,
"a menu at an expensive
restaurant with every course
crossed out except the soup,
and a footnote to the effect
that the soup
might not be served
in certain circumstances."
Refugees, in other words,
spun further from rights-based
agency--
a kind of global citizenship--
and further into compassionate
uncanniness.
Now, back in 1939,
Dorothy Thompson
had argued that there
can be no solution,
she said, to the refugee problem
as long as the world is divided
into absolutely
sovereign states,
anticipating
Barnett's observation
about the tenacity of the
opposition between citizens
and refugees.
Now since then, of course,
forms of global sovereignty
have changed--
changed a great deal.
But significantly,
the categories
of the citizen and
the refugee have
remained stubbornly intact.
If anything of late, in Europe,
Australia, and here in the US,
have become more tenaciously--
we might even say maniacally--
attached to that opposition.
Now the solution to the
so-called refugee crisis today
cannot, I think, be only more
horrified humanitarianism.
Only because the first
solution to the refugee problem
was already to
humanitarianize it,
to take away rights and push
a humanitarian argument.
This is not about help.
It's another phrase from today
that's ringing in my head.
In the process, the
placeless condition,
and its real challenges to
thinking about what citizenship
means, were neutralized.
And the opportunity,
which I think
was seen clearly by Arendt's
generation along with any may
others, to think about the
kinds of citizenship that
might be available beyond
national sovereignty was
squandered, was lost.
Which leads me by
way of conclusion
to the kinds of conversations
about citizenship and refugees
that are happening today.
Not in the global vernacular
of humanitarianism,
human rights aid,
crisis, with what I think
is rather dodgy moral
grammar of uncanny compassion
and its talk of
solutions to problems
that it has caused,
often, indeed,
by its compassionate
humanitarian solution;
but in the women's bathroom of
the politics department of St.
Joseph's in Beirut
today, where I
like to think Hannah Arendt
is kind of hanging out
as a friendly ghost as
those women scholars discuss
the future of citizenship.
Now, Lebanon as you all know,
along with Jordan and Turkey,
is one of the major
hosts of Syrian refugees.
And has long been a
nation whose politics
have been defined by refugee
history, particularly
Palestinian refugee history.
Now back in 2010, there
were several different ways
in which it was possible for
Syrians to come to Lebanon
after the war broke out.
You could register as a refugee
with the United Nations High
Commission for
Refugees, but then you'd
have to agree not to work.
So that's more passive
humanitarianism.
You'd have to agree
to give up that right.
Well, not that you
actually had that right.
You'd have to agree not
to try and claim it.
If you were rich enough, you
could buy a residency permit
which would allow you to
work, but you could only
do that with the sponsorship
of a Lebanese citizen.
So a kind of
adjunct citizenship.
Or you could decide
that your best
bet was to lose your
passport at the border
and pass like a ghost into
one of the legal and political
twilight communities
of the displaced
and their hosts that are
now a permanent feature not
only in Lebanon and
across the Middle East
but across the world.
Now one such place is
Beddawi in northern Lebanon,
a Palestinian refugee camp
established by UNRWA in 1955
and home now to at
least three generations
of Palestinian refugees.
Since 2010, Beddawi has
also been host to thousands
fleeing the war in Syria.
And the camp can't move
out because it's only given
so much land, so it's moved up.
It is very, very crowded.
In Beddawi, as in
similar communities,
the opposition between
citizens and refugees
is not operative-- not
out of any utopianism,
but out of history
and sheer necessity.
Survival depends on a mutual
and precarious and, importantly,
constantly-negotiated
compassion between
different nationalities,
histories, traumas, needs,
desires, and political hopes.
We often talk about
humanitarian crises.
But in Beddawi, as in elsewhere,
it makes much more sense
I think to talk about emergency
or crisis citizenship.
The citizenship
at issue may well
not depend on the state or,
indeed, the nation state
to define it or keep it safe.
So it might as well be left
in the bathroom for now.
But if we want to get beyond
peer pity and suspicion,
compassion and hate,
I think we would
do well just now to learn
from those who have no choice
but to try out new
modes of being together.
With this in mind,
I'd like to end
by quoting from my
refugee hosts collaborator
the Beddawi-born poet
Yousif Mohammed Qasmiyeh
and his beautiful acknowledgment
of what it means to share
the placeless condition.
He writes, "Refugees
ask refugees,
who are we to come to you and
who are you to come to us?
Nobody answers.
Palestinians, Syrians,
Iraqis, Kurds share the camp.
The same-different camp,
the camp of a camp.
They have all come to
re-originate the beginning
with their own hands and feet."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you all very much.
So these are really
very rich and thought
provoking contributions
with interesting overlaps
and interesting divergences.
And I really wonder
whether each of you
might like to ask
each other questions,
because there seems
so much conversation
sort of between these papers.
But maybe I'll just
start off by saying
that what I found so
fascinating is that each of you
really problematize and give a
new lens on something that we
see as familiar and
transparent, and actually
make us look at it in
a very different light.
So Theresa I found
your presentation
about the US-Canada border
absolutely extraordinary.
I never thought about
this in all my years
of working on borders and on
militarisation of borders.
And we always talk
about the militarization
of the southern border.
But what you showed was
really so starkly shocking.
And I don't know if I'm
the only one in this room
to be so shocked, but it is--
I think you really performed an
extraordinarily useful service
to us by just demonstrating the
kind of violence of the attack
on these actually peace loving
native communities who've
been there forever, and the
imposition of as you rightly
said this colonial division.
So really, my
question to you is,
what remedies might be
the most productive,
given that the law is
certainly not going to deliver?
Because the law actually
instantiates and reifies
part of the problem by
generating this border
and by sort of discrediting
the sense of openness.
So what remedies might
be most productive
do you think in challenging this
sort of blatant use of state
violence against
these communities?
So maybe I'll just maybe
pose a few questions.
And then you can
address them or not.
Just like other
chairs said, you know.
Alex's presentation, sort
of in a different way,
of course, also extremely
and equally disturbing.
And I just wondered
something very practical.
Like you didn't give us
a sense of scale here.
You know, are we
talking about tens,
hundreds, thousands, millions
of people who think this way?
You know, occasionally
an event erupts.
You know, what happened
just now in New Zealand,
where you see the
sort of underbelly
of this sort of
white supremacism
or ethno-nationalism.
But one is normally not
really following it,
unless you're part
of those sites.
So it would be very
useful, I think,
to get a sense from you
of the scale of this.
I mean, is this a
kind of phantasma?
Is this just a kind of
deluded kind of paranoid dream
these people have of
deporting everybody
who doesn't fit the kind
of white nationalist mode,
or is this actually a serious
political threat that we should
be really addressing
maybe more than we do?
Or is that a false dichotomy,
are elements of this threat
seeping in different ways?
But I just wondered.
And Lyndsey, I absolutely
loved your paper.
And I think that what
you say about the kind
of symbiotic relationship
between refugees and citizens
is actually really
thought provoking
and I haven't thought
about that enough myself.
But I wondered
about what you were
saying at the end about
this kind of question
of new modes of being together.
It sounds so utopian
at a moment where
we are riven by new modes
of not being together
and the impossibility
of being together.
And even in the
context of camps,
we know that-- and I've
seen this certainly
at some of the camps
I've been to-- we
see tremendous rivalries
between Syrians
and Iraqis and Afghans,
born out of dire scarcity
and the kind of
tensions that arise.
But is this a
serious proposition
you think, politically,
that one might think
of new ways of building
on the common exclusion
from first-class citizenship,
and that this might really
provide a new way
of being together
and of organizing and creating
a kind of political solidarity?
Or is this more a
kind of reflection
on the kind of humanistic
spirit that still manages
to survive despite all else?
So these are just some of my
rather disparate reflections.
But if you'd like to
address them, please do.
And if you wouldn't like
to, then please don't.
- Well, do you want
to start, since--
- OK.
It is not at all utopian.
It's, you know, to be
very British about it,
it's bloody awful.
And it's made even more awful
at the moment because of-- going
back to some of the themes
of these invisible borders,
the Trump decision to cut
funding for UNRWA, now means--
and UNRWA is very important
in Palestinian camps because--
- Does everybody in the
audience know what UNRWA is?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Sorry.
- Maybe just explain.
- So it's-- the United
Nations set up an organization
specifically for Palestinians
to look after them in 1948.
OK?
So that's a humanitarian
aid organization.
And it's been
important insofar it
offers limited humanitarian
support for people in the camps
and has done since '48.
So some health care,
a lot of the schools.
And a lot of people who
work for UNWRA are refugees.
Their Palestinians.
So it's not a kind of, you
know, particularly, only
paternalistic mode.
But it's also very important
because UNRWA's existence
says that the world recognizes
the Palestinians are
dispossessed because
they're in need of aid.
So it's political as well.
So the Trump
administration last year
decided to withdraw
funding from UNRWA.
The catastrophic effects
of that are already
being felt in the camp.
So in Beddawi, there's no
antibiotics left already,
and it's only three months in.
And then schools are closing.
And it was a kind of
political move in terms of aid
as well, because it's
like saying, actually,
the world doesn't
recognize that you have
this thing done to you now.
Because we're dismantling UNRWA.
So to go back to Jacqui's point,
it's not a utopianism at all.
But I think it goes back
to earlier points that
have been made, that out
of situations of emergency
and survival, there are new
ways of coming in together.
And I also do think
that in Europe,
and I'm sure this is
happening in the US
as well, because
things are so dreadful,
there are new solidarities
that happening particularly
with younger activists,
legal activists, people
who are working in
the Greek islands who
don't have to be there
but they've gone out
and they've helped.
And they're forging
different definitions
of international
solidarity that are outside
of the postwar consensus.
And we don't know
what those are yet.
I mean, in some ways we're
just glad they're there,
because they are actually
stopping some people getting
drowned and they are
feeding some people
and they are providing
minimal conditions.
But that generation of people
are also creating new networks.
So, you know, across
from Palestinians
to Greeks to people
from Sub-Saharan Africa,
to other refugees.
Across the solidarities between
Central American and South
America, and that kind of global
something, that's all growing.
So that could be, not
utopian, but it's happening.
And new definitions of
citizenship are being born.
We don't know what
they're going to be yet,
but I'm dang glad
they're giving it a go.
- Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE] helpful.
Yeah, Alex.
- Yeah, well, the issue of
scale is very important.
And there's very little
research on this,
in terms of understanding
beliefs of the alt-right
because of its
fairly new emergence
and also because
of the difficulty
of studying something
that exists for the most
part in social media, in a
landscape that is ephemeral,
where there's not
much accountability,
and where we're seeing
a lot of movement
around de-platforming and
suspension of various sites,
which is a good thing that
these are being recognized
and regulated.
One of the few studies
that was done used--
let me just make sure
I get this right--
the American national
election survey data in 2016
to look at what percentage
of the white population
concurs with beliefs that are
in sync with white nationalism.
And the researcher
that did this study
looked at three core beliefs--
a strong sense of
white identity,
a belief in white
solidarity, and a feeling
of white victimization--
and determined that
based on this sample
that approximately 6% of
the white population or 11
million white people
agree with those three.
However, if you take them
separately, about 30% to 40%
of white people agree with
at least one of those.
And that number of
30% to 40% is actually
one that's good to keep in
mind because other studies that
have looked at the rise
of authoritarianism
in Europe and the
propensity to support
authoritarian
leadership seems to find
a steady rate of around 35%,
particularly of young people.
And this is something
to be aware of-- what
we call the millennial or
the zoomers generation who,
you know, would respond
to questions that
would support authoritarianism.
And this is also
happening in a context
where we have the rise
of national populism,
ethno-nationalism, and a lot
of cross traffic of these ideas
that are moving from the
alternative-- you know,
alternative for Germany,
to what's happened recently
with the elections
in the Netherlands,
to what happened in New Zealand.
So it's really important to put
it in a transnational context.
My idea is to not--
I don't want to
sensationalize this.
But we also don't
want to trivialize it.
So in my own work, I'm always
seeking to find that balance.
- Thank you.
Theresa?
- I just have some thoughts--
in terms of what I'm talking
about-- just the extent
to which settler
colonialism itself
remains so unaddressed in
social justice movements
and organizing.
That people don't sort of
examine that core, that it just
keeps going on in ways.
People do things in ways
that continue to reify that,
even though they're
sort of seeking
justice, more inclusion,
better ways of living.
And just that the kinds of
intersections and alliances
that could be built
from interrogating
that more thoroughly.
- It is so interesting, because
in that cross-border context,
you think about third
country nationals,
and whether or not people
could be sent back from Canada
to the US.
Is US a safe country?
I mean, that's the
domain in which I work.
But that's not at all
talking about native peoples.
It completely is talking
about refugees or undocumented
or migrants.
- Mm-hmm.
Yeah, and I just think, for
people to even really start
to ask, like, why is our
political difference so
threatening?
I mean, it's important to
us because we have treaties
with the United States
and with Canada.
That also should be important
to Canadians and Americans,
because that's also how
they get their rights.
And, you know, those
relationships--
those nation to nation
relationships-- are vital.
And they should remain intact.
And there's lots
of, actually, ways
that people could
think about those
and build in the
way in which they
can move to help
other movements,
help other causes and issues.
I mean, I have rarely seen the
environmental movement sort
of talk about how
indigenous treaties
and indigenous sovereignty could
be helpful to those movements.
It doesn't necessarily
occur to people
when it can be
incredibly helpful.
And I think with
these more recent--
what I showed as my
sort of border actions--
I think people are actually
starting to catch on to that
and to think about how these
are actual legal political
relationships that
can be traced.
And they're not enforced
because there really
isn't a critical mass now
pushing for that enforcement.
And so there is so much
potential there, I think.
Like I said, I want
to talk about how
indigenous citizenship and
sovereignty can actually
help other people in
other movements as well.
- Thank you.
Well, thank you for
those very rich comments.
So we have a few minutes left.
So if we have any questions,
could people please line up
and ask those questions?
Thank you.
Yeah.
Please go ahead.
- Hi.
My name is Becky Thompson.
I want to appreciate the
panel and this entire day.
I wanted to share a little
bit about refugee solidarity
and then pose a
question as well.
So for those of us who've
been in Greece since 2015,
and also in Beirut, what
we have been witnessing
is a tremendous amount
of refugee activism.
And that comes, in part,
because of the need for people
to be saving each other's lives.
So I think, for
example, of people
waiting in Izmir
in Turkey, wanting
to come across on the rafts.
And the smugglers are
not saying, excuse me,
the only people on the
rafts can be Syrian.
Right?
So what that means
is that people
are coming across and
fearing for their lives,
creating solidarity with
each other in that moment.
So Afghans and Kurds and
Palestinians and Syrians
together.
And then walking up the
mountain pass in Lesbos
all the way to Mytelini.
And what I was witnessing
over and over again
is, any time an elder
needed to sit on a backpack,
it didn't matter what
country that elder was from,
especially if she was a woman,
she would get that backpack.
And then you see now in
[INAUDIBLE] and in [INAUDIBLE]
and in [INAUDIBLE]
organizing happening across
so many ethnicities
and religion as well.
So I want to lift that up
as, you know, coming back
each time I'm thinking, if we
had here the kind of solidarity
that we are seeing
there, we would
be in a whole other
place in terms
of transnational solidarity.
- So your question, please.
- So my question, then, is
to you about what examples
you have seen in your
own work of the activism
and the crossing of boundaries
that wouldn't have otherwise
been crossed.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Lyndsey.
- Yeah.
Well, I think you gave
really good examples,
and I'd be tempted
to say the same.
But going back to
Jacqui's point,
I think those things happen,
as you've pointed out,
out of situations of survival.
And what is very interesting
is they're usually
not being administered.
In any resource-deprived
situation,
you're going to get fighting.
I mean, some people
will scrapped
because of this resource.
And what you have what
you had in Lebanon,
and slightly
differently in Jordan,
is Syrian refugees could come
on to the United Nations High
Commission for Refugees and
have a certain streaming
and slightly more aid--
because there was Syrian--
than Palestinians.
And it was the administrative
nature of humanitarianism
that was feeding
divisions, whereas what's
happening in some of the
situations you were describing
and also in other
parts of the world,
including Jordan, is a
different type of solidarity.
And a Sheikh said
to me in a workshop
we were running in Jordan--
we were running
workshops with people
who were hosting refugees
and refugees themselves.
Quite often, people
who are hosting
refugees in Jordan and Lebanon
come from refugee families
themselves.
Largely Palestinian or another
kind of tradition or going way
back.
So there is a kind of
identification there.
And the Sheikh said to me, we
don't have the word refugee
here.
That's yours.
That's Western.
We have guests and strangers.
And technically, he's right.
I mean, that's what
Michael Barnett
was saying in the history
of humanitarianism.
We invented this
category of refugee
in order to administer those
people who were not citizens.
They're actually
people who are moving
for all sorts of reasons.
And so one of the
things we need to do
is invent a different
language for talking
about hosting, guesting,
staying, staying
too long maybe.
Being an awkward
guest, whatever.
It's never easy, we know.
Many people [INAUDIBLE].
But we desperately need
to find another language.
And I think you're right.
I think some of that
is happening out
of sheer necessity,
not out of utopianism.
No one is being an
idealist at the moment.
It's too grim.
- Thank you.
I'm going to just exercise
my prerogative as the chair
and ask each of the four
people standing there
to ask their question,
and ask the three of you
to make notes as necessary.
And then we'll answer everybody.
And we'll then have time to hand
over for the final comments.
Yeah.
Sir.
- Thank you.
Again, I'm David Alan.
I want to take
seriously this idea
of leaving behind the
notion of the nation state.
If not in the toilet,
at least behind.
And it occurs that--
actually, a
startling observation
from the very first presentation
might offer us a framework
for thinking forward.
Again, in practical terms.
That observation
was that this event
is taking place on Wampanoag
land, where we stand today.
And why is that suggestive?
Because if we would try to do
something serious about that,
we'd have to dismantle all the
forms of property ownership,
such as Harvard's
ownership of this land.
At least there'd have
to be resolutions.
Just as if we were going to
move beyond the nation state,
we would have to
not only dismantle
the building block for all
the world's organization,
and certainly a
lot of democracies,
and move to some other form.
So I invite-- yes,
it's a bit startling,
the notion of turning
back over to the Wampanoag
where we're standing, but it
might jolt us out of ourselves
to think of this problem
in very practical terms.
How might we move beyond the
building block of the nation
state?
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- My name is [? Winn ?]
[? Quayle. ?] Thank you
for your panel.
There were several
references to the concept
of race during this panel and
of course other panels earlier
today.
And we heard a lot of
discussion about the concept
of blood purity.
I'm not a scientist.
But my question relates
to the relationship
between a biological
conception of race
and a social conception,
and whether--
since now everyone can have
their genes sequenced--
is it possible that white
nationalists might find out
that they're related
to African-Americans
and whether any
of that might have
some consequences for these
political discussions?
- Hannah.
- Hello.
My name is Hannah.
I'm from the graduate school
of design here at Harvard.
I only yesterday heard about
this term polypolitanism,
which the professor used
instead of cosmopolitanism.
It's an idea that we can
belong to many instead
of either nation state or
international, so it to me
was very hopeful.
And it sounded very
realizable that we
don't have to sort of
dismantle everything
that we have in order to
go for another future.
But we can actually have
more than one identity,
and I resonate with that.
And I think a lot of people
resonate with wanting
to navigate as multiple
sort of people.
So yeah.
So I was wondering if
you had any thoughts
on this idea of
polypolitanism and if you
have any critiques of that.
I'm just curious what
you thought of that.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much, indeed.
So who'd like to start?
Alex, why don't you start?
- I can start.
The question of ancestry
testing and white nationalism
is a very interesting one.
And what researchers
have found--
and, you know, you
can learn about
if you actually go into
some of these message boards
where white nationalists or
focusing on ancestry testing
is they like the
results of the test
when they tell them
what they want to hear.
But they actually don't rely--
they like the idea of the tests.
And that's in fact why the
American Society for Human
Genetics recently made
a very strong statement
against white supremacy
and the misuse
of these tests, the
scientific distortion of them
by white supremacists.
They specifically
used that term.
However, one of
the aspects that's
very interesting about
white nationalists
is, because they
don't they frequently
don't get the results
they want, they
engage in a romanticized
notion of community.
They often ignore genetic tests.
They partake of the
metaphors of blood and soil.
But for example, if they
don't get a result they want,
they'd say, well, I'm
white in spirit and soul.
Or I feel a connection to the
medieval past or the Crusades.
And there's a lot of
these fantasy invocations.
So this is happening on
multiple discursive levels.
But the ancestry testing
does kind of cross that,
and that will continue to
play a role in certain aspects
of at least claiming identity.
- Thank you.
Theresa, do you want to comment
on Harvard handing over--
[LAUGHTER]
- OK, good.
I think-- where to start?
One of the things we
talk about, there's
a lot of debate about
doing land acknowledgments.
And part of it is because
people don't want it just become
like a rote one off thing.
They want people to
sort of think like--
it's not invisible anymore.
It's not erased anymore.
But to think about
this idea of, OK,
what is the relationship that
comes with that acknowledgment?
Because you're asking
this big question.
How do we dismantle?
You know, what is this
anti-colonial vision?
It starts with
having relationships.
And moving out of possession
to relationship, I think,
is where it has to start.
So acknowledging that.
And then, OK,
where do we go now?
What do we do to build
those relationships
and to keep them
going and to have
that be an ongoing process?
In our earliest
treaties that we have
between Haudenosaunee
people and the newcomers,
they were treaties of
peace and friendship.
And they were
treaties about ways
to coexist and to have
independent political systems,
but to exist in a
non-colonial relationship
where there wasn't
imposition or interference.
And so those visions
are out there.
And they're principled on
these ideas of having relations
in a different way that aren't
about necessarily possession,
and can we think about
sort of structuring
things more along those lines.
- Yeah.
No, but back to
the nation state.
Because there's not one
type of nation state.
It's always changing
and can change.
I really was touched
by your translation
of what nationality means.
Bodies in the land.
And I just thought that's really
powerful and that could work.
And then it all kind of
looked back to this morning.
And actually what we
have at the moment
is a version of a nation
state which isn't actually
about sharing and
solidarity, or just sharing,
learning how to share.
As the panel pointed out,
it's about power and money
and a version of a fantasy
nation state, which is actually
about keeping power and money
for certain types of people.
So I wouldn't want to trash
the idea of the nation state
because I don't think there's
just one idea of the nation
state.
They're always competing,
arguing about the best way
to be together.
But I do think-- and that's why
I love the bodies in the land--
it's time to have more of an
upfront struggle about defining
new definitions of
what it might mean
to be in the nation or
different nations in one state.
I mean bi-nationality,
tri-nationality,
poly-nationality
within one state
were options in the '40s that
people we're talking about
and just got closed down.
I think it's time to have
those conversations again.
- Terrific.
Well, thank you so much.
I think a measure of a good
panel and a good conference
is where people are really
listening to each other,
picking up each other's phrases,
incorporating them, learning
from them.
And I think by that
criterion, this
has been a fabulous conference.
So I think I can
speak for all of us
when I say a big thank you to
Radcliffe for organizing this.
[APPLAUSE]
- I wanted to give a couple
of concluding remarks
today, thanking first off all
of you who came and shared
your time and in many cases
your questions and remarks,
or your concerns.
I want to begin just a couple
of quick notes of gratitude
to our dean Tomiko Brown-Nagin
for her leadership,
to the academic ventures
group at Radcliffe that puts
on events like these and
its fearless leader Rebecca
Wasserman, and to
the event staff,
Jessica [? Vicland ?] and others
who do just such an amazing job
bringing these
kinds of complex--
highly complex--
events to fruition.
Let me also once again
thank the committee
that I was privileged to
join, the planning committee,
and my colleagues on the
planning committee, which
include Professor Phil Deloria.
I see you.
Professor Jiyun Kim.
And Professor
Gabriela Soto Laveaga.
They did just such
an amazing job.
I mean, the diversity of
perspectives, geographies,
spaces, voices that
you heard, that's them.
And I really can't
emphasize that enough.
Becky Wasserman, too.
But it's really just a
remarkable accomplishment.
So what did we do today?
What did we do to citizenship?
I'd like to think we kind
of unsettled it a bit.
Right?
Busted it apart.
Is there anything
left to it anymore?
We learned from Sabeel Rahman
that it's not one off, one on.
It's not binary.
It's not like a light switch.
It's more smooth.
It's functional,
continuous, convex.
It gets undone by
economic power,
to the extent that economic
relations can render
it fictive, almost, as we
learned from Zephyr Teachout
whose talk was really scary.
But really persuasive.
It has been used, as our
indigenous friends have
reminded us, as a cudgel
to forcibly assimilate
the indigenous peoples of
North America and elsewhere.
We learned that
from Rosita Worl.
from Jill Doerfler.
Citizenship has been
used to reassemble
a fictional white majority,
a fictional white community
as Professor Minna
Stern just noted.
And as Lyndsey [INAUDIBLE]
just reminded us,
citizenship's
residual categories
define those outside
of them as people,
as agents, of somehow
having less value,
less permanence, less
belonging than those within.
And finally, perhaps
more most poignantly,
[INAUDIBLE] reminded us
that sometimes citizenship
isn't enough.
You can have all the
formal citizenship,
but it doesn't deliver
the antibiotics, the food,
the water that
needs to be there.
I'm not ready to throw in
the towel on citizenship
yet, though.
And while I don't
have any answers,
let me just point
a couple of paths
forward, really not so much for
progress in the global sense,
but in ways that we can think
about it that are really
just inspired by if not just
pure repetitions of what
you heard earlier today.
We need more than
citizenship, obviously.
But maybe we also need a
transformed citizenship.
Maybe unsettling
citizenship, making
it unruly, unruled
in that respect,
is exactly what we
need to save it.
And once saved or once
appropriately transformed,
maybe we need what it provides,
namely rights and governments
in the best sense.
Maybe we need the
kind of citizenship
that respects the
sovereignty and treaties
of indigenous
communities and citizens.
Maybe we need governmental
resources properly
laid out to protect human rights
and those most vulnerable,
whether they're the
poor, whether they're
the refugee, whether they're
indigenous citizens, what
have you.
Maybe we need a more
encompassing vision
of citizenship that
rejects racist thinking
and imagined Edens or that
refashions the museum much
as Pap Ndiaye is doing
right now in Paris.
And maybe we need a form of
citizenship that calls us
to the kind of commitment and
vitality that Mayor Carmen
Yuln Cruz Soto
called us to today.
And on that note, I really
can't do any better.
And none of us could do
any better than the way
that she marshaled
our aspirations
at that wonderful
keynote address.
I hope that and
all of this remain
with you, the questions, the
aspirations, the inspiration.
Go on and be good citizens.
And have a great weekend.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]